REBUKED AGAIN.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
THE ELITES HAVE NEVER ACCEPTED
THE FACT THAT POPULIST
CONSERVATIVES AND ECONOMIC
NATIONALISTS AROUND THE GLOBE
ARE ON THE RISE.
HERE IN THE U.S., THINK ABOUT
IT.
THE DEEP STATE ROSE UP AGAINST
TRUMP DURING AND AFTER THE
ELECTION BY USING INFORMANTS,
FISA COURTS, SURVEILLANCE
POWERS, AND A SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION TWO YEARS,
$35 MILLION, TO TRY TO OUST HIM
FROM OFFICE.
IN THE END, WE ARE GOING TO FIND
OUT THAT THE OBAMA DOJ DID A LOT
MORE TO HURT AMERICA AND THE
SYMPATHETIC RUSSIAN HACKERS EVER
COULD.
EVER SINCE TRUMP WAS ELECTED,
THE GLOBAL ESTABLISHMENT HAS
SUFFERED FROM WISHFUL THINKING
SYNDROME.
>> A HUGE BLOW TO THE WAVE OF
POPULISM THAT HELPS SEEK
DONALD TRUMP INTO OFFICE.
>> NATIONALISM VERSUS GLOBALISM.
IN THIS CASE, THE GROWING TIDE
OF POPULISM APPEARS TO HAVE
RECEDED.
>> NO QUESTION THIS WAS A BIG
BLOW TO WHAT'S BEING CALLED KNOW
NOTHING POPULISM.
>> YOU CANNOT LOOK AT THE
SELECTION IN ANY OTHER WAY BUT
TO SEE IT A REPUDIATION OF TRUM
TRUMP.
>> Laura: HOW CAN SO MANY
PEOPLE GET PAID IT TO BE SO
CONSISTENTLY WRONG?
AND THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
EXPERTS.
OF COURSE, YOU MIGHT'VE HEARD
OVER THE WEEKEND POPULIST,
NATIONALIST MADE STUNNING GAINS
IN THE E.U. ELECTIONS,
ESPECIALLY IN BRITAIN.
REMEMBER, THREE YEARS AGO, NIGEL
FARAGE OF THE UKIP PARTY FORCED
A REFERENDUM WHERE THE VOTE
CHOSE TO LEAVE THE EUROPEAN
PARTY, THE SO-CALLED BREXIT.
BUT EVER SINCE THEN, THE
ESTABLISHED WHEN PARTIES HAVE
DONE EVERYTHING IN THEIR POWER
TO SLOW THINGS DOWN OR JUST A
TWINED OF WART THE WILL OF THE
PEOPLE ALTOGETHER.
TWO PRIME MINISTER IS LATER, THE
PEOPLE STILL DON'T HAVE THEIR
INDEPENDENCE FROM THEIR
BUREAUCRATS IN BRUSSELS.
SIX WEEKS AGO, FARAGE CAME OUT
OF RETIREMENT AND FOUNDED THE
BREXIT PARTY.
IN A STUNNING REBUKE OF THE OLD
LABOUR AND CONSERVATIVE PARTIES,
IT WON NEARLY 32% OF THE VOTE
AND CAPTURED 29 SEATS IN THE
EUROPEAN PARLIAMENT, WITH THE
OTHER PARTIES BASICALLY
OBLITERATED.
IT WAS THE WORST NATIONAL
ELECTION FOR THERESA MAY'S
CONSERVATIVE PARTY EVER.
LIKE THE TRUMP VICTORY BACK IN
2016, FARAGE LED AN INSURGENT
CAMPAIGN AND HE STUCK TO HIS
MESSAGE.
THE U.K. WANTS OUT OF THE E.U.
>> AT THE END OF THE DAY, IT'S
ABOUT WHAT BASES WANT.
I THINK EITHER THE CONSERVATIVE
OR LIBERAL PARTIES TAKE US
TOWARDS BREXIT OR THEY ARE GOING
TO HAVE TO BE REPLACED.
IT'S AS SIMPLE AS THAT.
>> Laura: IN FRANCE, MARIE
LE PEN'S NATIONAL RALLY PARTY
BEAT OUT MACRON'S PRO E.U.
CENTRIST PARTY, WINNING THE MOST
SEATS AT THE E.U.
NATIONALISTS IN ITALY ALSO TOOK
THE MOST SEATS.
ALL OF EUROPE, PEOPLE ARE BUT
THEY'LL MAKE DEMANDING THEIR
FREEDOM FROM THE INTERNATIONAL
SHACKLES PUT ON BY REGULATORS WH
SHACKLES PUT ON BY REGULATORS WO
SHACKLES PUT ON BY REGULATORS WD
SHACKLES PUT ON BY REGULATORS WN
SHACKLES PUT ON BY REGULATORS WT
SHACKLES PUT ON BY REGULATORS WK
SHACKLES PUT ON BY REGULATORS WO
SHACKLES PUT ON BY REGULATORS WW
AND CAN'T RESPOND TO THEIR
PEOPLE OR THEIR NEEDS.
WHILE MOST ARE FINE TO HAVE
STRONG ECONOMIC RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THEIR MEMBER NATIONS, THE
POPULISTS, THE MORE ECONOMIC
NATIONALISM AMONG THEM STILL
WANT TO RETAIN THEIR LANGUAGE,
THEIR BORDERS, AND THEIR OWN
UNIQUE CULTURE.
AND WHEN YOU READ
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" THOUGH, OR
CNN, YOU LISTEN TO THEM, THEY
ALWAYS USE THE WORD
"ANTI-IMMIGRANT" OR "FAR RIGHT
PARTIES MADE THE GAME."
ALMOST INVARIABLY THAT
DISTINCTION IS FALSE.
AGAIN, THE SLIME HAS BEEN THROWN
AT TRUMP OR SOLVE ANY OR LE PEN,
OR VIKTOR ORBAN IN HUNGARY, AND
MET ONLY TWO DENIGRATES, NOT
TO ADVANCE AN ACTUAL DEBATE TO I
TO ADVANCE AN ACTUAL DEBATE TO P
TO ADVANCE AN ACTUAL DEBATE TO O
TO ADVANCE AN ACTUAL DEBATE TO E
TO ADVANCE AN ACTUAL DEBATE TO P
TO ADVANCE AN ACTUAL DEBATE TO O
TO ADVANCE AN ACTUAL DEBATE TO L
TO ADVANCE AN ACTUAL DEBATE TO '
TO ADVANCE AN ACTUAL DEBATE TO S
TO ADVANCE AN ACTUAL DEBATE TO A
TO ADVANCE AN ACTUAL DEBATE TO D
TO ADVANCE AN ACTUAL DEBATE TO R
OF LIVING.
TIME AFTER TIME, RATHER THAN
LISTEN TO THE PEOPLE AND USE THE
MOMENTS THAT THESE MOMENTS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN AND CHANGE,
INSTEAD OF THE GLOBAL ELITES
JUST RUNNING IN OTHER DIRECTION.
I THINK OF ANGELA MERKEL, THE
WOMAN RESPONSIBLE FOR EUROPE'S
ADMISSION OF 1 MILLION PLUS
REFUGEES.
LET'S FACE IT, THAT HAS BEEN A
DISASTER FROM ITALY TO SWEDEN
AND EVERYWHERE IN BETWEEN.
THE GERMAN CHANCELLOR HAS
SHE ANSWERED A REPORTER'S
QUESTION AND THAT REPORTER WAS
EQUALLY IN DENIAL.
>> UNDER YOUR MAYBE 15 YEARS OF
POWER, IN SOME CASES THOSE DARK
OLD STEVENS HAVE RISEN AGAIN.
>> GERMANY CAN AND WILL NOT
UNCOUPLE ITSELF FROM THE
DEVELOPMENT WE SEEK ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
WE SEE THIS IN GERMANY AS WELL,
BUT IN GERMANY OBVIOUSLY IT
ALWAYS HAS TO BE SEEN IN A
CERTAIN CONTEXT, THE CONTEXT OF
OUR PAST WHICH MEANS WE HAVE TO
BE THAT MUCH MORE VIGILANT THAN
OTHERS.
WE HAVE TO TELL OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
WHAT HISTORY HAS BROUGHT OVER TO
OTHERS, AND THESE HORRORS.
>> Laura: THE HORRORS?
WELL.
IN OTHER WORDS, IF YOU VOTED FOR
A POPULIST OR NATIONALIST PARTY,
YOU ARE ESSENTIALLY IN SOME WAY
EMPATHIZING WITH, WHAT, HITLER,
OR HITLER IN WAITING?
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
ITALIAN DEPUTY PRIME MINISTER
SALVINI HAD THE PERFECT RESPONS.
>>
>> [SPEAKING ITALIAN]
>> Laura: THE ELITES ARE BEING
REJECTED BECAUSE THEY FAILED.
THEY HAVE BEEN ROUTED.
THE WORST RESULTS ARE COMING
THEIR WAY BECAUSE THEY REFUSE TO
HEAR THE VOTERS.
WHAT TRUMP HAVE SHOWN HERE AT
HOME?
A STRONG'S MUSCULAR APPROACH ON
TRADE, LOWER TAXES, FEWER
REGULATIONS, AND THE FOREIGN
POLICY BASED IMPRUDENT REALISM.
IT'S ALL PAYING OFF.
CHECK OUT OUR ECONOMY COMPARED
TO EUROPE'S.
BASICALLY NO COMPARISON
WHATSOEVER.
LOOK AT THAT.
E.U., 1.5% GDP.
U.S., 3.2% GDP.
UNEMPLOYMENT ABOUT, ALMOST
DOUBLED IN EUROPE.
TRANSLATION?
TRUMP'S POLICIES WORK.
AS THE EUROPEAN MODEL BARELY
LIMPS ALONG.
WHAT IF THE EUROPEAN VOTERS ARE
RESTLESS.
LOOK AT MORE BIG MOVES AGAINST